tt s'ils allaient le psychiatrique de la
cité de la santé à laval qu'abdullah
shaik a été interné pour la dernière
fois à l'été 2000 21 un séjour d'environ
deux semaines marquées par l'agressivité
et les menaces de l'homme de 26 ans
envers le personnel soignant et menace
des menaces l'oat 10 ans j'ai trouvé
ton nom complet ton adresse je vais lui
c'était récurrents c'était irrégulier le
pendant son séjour des membres du
personnel de l'hôpital qui s'occupait
d'abdullah shaikh était terrorisée au
point où un intervenant en santé mentale
a voulu porter plainte à la police de
laval il a appelé la police mais la
police à l'époque au dit que c'était des
menaces voilées que c'est un patient et
tant pis si six mois après ce séjour la
commission d'examen pour troubles
mentaux a accordé abdullah chèque le
droit de séjourner à l'extérieur de
l'établissement de santé selon le
rapport consulté par radio canada il
représentait toujours un risque élevé
pour la sécurité publique les personnes
peuvent demeurer en société avec un
suivi très étroite avec une équipe
médicale compétente avec
également l'équipe médicale est allié
avec la famille on s'assure que la
personne la médication il était connu du
réseau de la santé depuis 2018 après
avoir été déclaré non criminellement
responsable pour cause de troubles
mentaux il avait commis le méfait de
brûler son passeport dans le terminal de
l'aéroport de montréal depuis quatre ans
il avait séjourné à l'hôpital en santé
mentale albert prévost puis à l'institut
philippe-pinel trois autres séjours en
psychiatrie ont été nécessaires à la
cité de la santé en raison de cette
imposante feuille de route des
conditions lui avait été imposée plaide
son avocat il y avait la confiance de
garder la paix
d'habiter dans un endroit qui est
approuvée par l'équipe très tard il y
avait également des comptes sur deux par
la médication la commission d'examen a
jugé que le risque était donc acceptable
de le suivre à distance malgré les
inquiétudes exprimées dans son rapport
concernant le déni et la banalisation
des troubles de comportement de la
violence et de la pathologie
psychiatrique on y indique également que
le patient a proféré de multiples
menaces implicites et explicites
lors de la dernière hospitalisation
je pense que monsieur
n'allait pas bien qui a passé à travers
les mailles quelque part françois
legault lui dit avoir parlé de ses
préoccupations
avec son conseil des ministres mais là
il faut voir aussi ce qui est arrivé
parce qu'étant donné que c'est quelqu'un
qui était déjà ciblé pourquoi il a été
relâché reste à savoir également comment
une personne atteinte de schizophrénie
avec un aussi l'eau passait dans le
réseau de la santé a bien pu se procurer
une arme à feu pour commettre une cavale
aussi meurtrière ici pascal robidas
radio-canada mon cas